do not waste your productive time doing
things that you can hire people to do
for five or ten dollars an hour use your
productive time on the on tasks that are
more expensive of higher value delegate
everything that you possibly can in fact
its General conclusion is this is that
if you cannot delegate if you cannot get
other people to do things of lower
priority for you you cannot grow you
cannot develop you cannot be successful
you may be successful running a shoe
shine stand but that's about the limit
of it delegation requires one key word
Clarity Clarity the reason people don't
delegate is because they're delegated
and other people have dropped the ball
but the major reason why people don't
fulfill the tasks that you've given to
them is because of lack of clarity so
when you delegate here are the keys
first of all think through what you want
done write it down second of all pick
the right person to do it don't give a
major task to an uh incapable person
third of all make it Crystal Clear what
you want done and when you want it done
and fourth of all check review inspect
keep on top of it to make sure it is
done on time